[Musique]
j'ai reçu un coup de fil hier d'un ami
entrepreneur basé en suisse
quelle entreprise de près de 40
personnes il avait l'air un peu alerté
au téléphone et je lui fais comment tu
vas y et moi ce qui se passe et me dit
écoute faut que je te parle blague rien
truc qui va pas je dis moi tout il se
met à pleurer au téléphone jeudi à
tenter un truc de vidal ça va être
dangereux
cela est grave dis moi tout dit écoute
j'ai un problème il faut que je
malheureusement que j'annonce la
faillite pour mon entreprise je dis
mince désolé pour toi s'est passé quoi
raconte - écoute un peu trop complexes
non par une autre fois par contre j'ai
une question à vous poser
il faut que je revends ma boîte pour un
franc suisse symbolique est ce que toi
ou une personne ton réseau serait
intéressé à la reprendre jeudi mais
pourquoi donc me la revendre pour ne pas
avoir de faillites enregistrées à mon
nom selon jyske du commerce
mon ami est plus peur du regard qu'à la
sphère les autres sur sa faillite que la
faillite en lui même on vit dans un
monde où la tchèque est pointé du doigt
il est évité c'est une bête noire on
parle pas en ligne or c'est les
personnes qui sont présentées ci qui
avec une période de chômage
les périodes des personnes qui ont
planté une start up les personnes qui
n'ont pas réussi en rendez-vous
d'embûches les personnes qui ont eu un
échec scolaire
on connaît tous sa c'est une bête noire
on n'en parle pas on les vite on ignore
on déguise on masque en cash
la honte mon nom est greg le guen j'ai
26 ans je vis en suisse je suis
entrepreneur jésus le roi de l'échec
merci
[Musique]
pour parler d'échec on va partir à ma
naissance je suis né un 29 février 2000
tempo assez rapidement donc directement
j'ai pu comprendre un peu ce qui allait
m'attendre j'ai depuis tout petit a été
passionné par le sport vraiment le sport
ça a été pour moi une sorte
d'échappatoire une passion vraiment une
passion réelle et j'avais ce rêve de
faire les jo j'étais bon en natation
faut qu on traînait comme un fou du
matin au soir tout par semaine 12
entraînements c'est un rythme assez
intense très soutenue j'ai été admis
dans une école spéciale pour sportif jef
est vice champion suisse de natation
mais j'avais ce rêve des jo c'est des
personnes qui sont présentes ici qui ont
eu ce rêve de faire les jo elles
comprendront rapidement c'est un rêve
qui nous passionne du matin au soir
quand tu transpires on le respire endort
gioan pense qu on respire gio tout le
temps tout le temps c'était coach et
psychologiquement au niveau de la
nourriture niveau du sport de l'école je
les cours que le matin et pas l'après
midi pour faire le sport donc sa grâce
et intense on va dire sauf qu'à un
instant forcément que le sport prenait
beaucoup de temps
même trop parfois j'ai pas mis assez
d'accent sur l'école donc j'ai été viré
des classes pour sportifs que j'avais
pas des notes suffisamment bonne j'en
appelle encore la lettre
je suis à la maison je t'écris vous avez
échoué d'une part je perdais ce rêve que
j'avais de faire les jo et d'autre part
je perdais mes amis de natation mais en
plus j'ai échoué
ma scolarité ça a été une période très
difficile personnellement de grosse
remise en question donc su retomber en
classe normale
si je peux le dire avec des personnes
standard normal non pas des personnes
sportives ont à dire dans la remet ça a
été très dur à subir le regard des
autres la perte d'un rêve est
directement l'impression qu'on est
marginale et dès qu'on perd un rêve on
perd une partie de soi aussi est cette
feuille que j'ai reçus de l'alcool
s'était pas écrit vous avez échoué pour
moi c'était que vous êtes en échec
j'ai perçu comme une sorte de faille la
personnalité donc très vite j'ai
retrouvé une autre passion le sport
c'est une grosse passion mon corps c'est
mon outil
j'ai un père qui est pilote de chasse en
suisse
donc je suis inscrit à l'armée suisse
c'est obligatoire en suisse si vous
seriez pas et l'armée de l'air ça ne
plaisait pas trop
par contre l'armée de terre le physique
sportif past and then donc je m'entraîne
comme un dingue du matin au soir pour
faire un éclaireur parachutistes
j'apprends un manuel de 300 pages parker
sur la voile je fais un saut en
parachute pour m'initier je m'entraîne
comme amphoux non-stop fait les deux
sélections je suis le meilleur de la
classe sportivement mais on me dit que
malheureusement je suis pas assez mature
malheureusement c'était une chance un
jour
donc j'avais pas de seconde chance on
m'a viré du coup de nouveau des
sélections en suisse il est notre armée
qui s'appelle et grenat dire c'est un
peu comme en france le l'armée de l'air
des parachutistes
c'est un peu l'élite suisse on va dire
série zone au tessin dans de nouveaux je
m'inscris au foot américain
je m'inscris à la boxe je m'entraîne
comme en foot nouveaux postes pour ce
rêve je me dis ah tiens grenadiers c'est
aussi une élite c'est très très dur d'y
arriver là que 12 personnes par
l'annexion sélectionné donc gimeno chez
les tests sportifs
je suis encore actuellement dans le top
10 de mes résultats bien le test de
mémoire et je fais un foutu 7 sur 10
madame monsieur il fallait 8 sur 10 pour
être sélectionné pour être grenadière
donc le recruteur m'a dit écoutez
monsieur le guen c'est bien ce que vous
allez faire mais malheureusement vous
avez pas les points qu'il faut vous
allez donc faire griller de chat je
garde le moment le mot grenadiers je
suis content de ça je commence l'armée
chef de chambre a dégradé monsieur logan
vous allez gradé vous allez faire qu'à
réaliser mon rêve enfin c'est défini je
vois une ligne qui se dressent devant
moi j'ai une équipe à gérer vraiment
jeune ma passion on va dire prend vie
enfin après trois semaines d'armé un
matin 4h du matin à tromper de somme
faut se réveiller
je suis premier debout à fond je me type
la troupe allez les gars on va courir
dehors on se met à courir autour d'un
langage et je trébuche sur une marche
d'escalier
je sens que c'est bizarre je veux dire
t'inquiète pas dans la tête ça va jouer
je cours je force moins une journée
sauf que ce soir je rentre j'ai une
jambe qui n'a pas un jour qui fait foi 3
la taille
je traîne ma jambe j'arrive plus à les
bouger je faire un test chez un médecin
et qui me dit écoutez monsieur le guen
vous êtes inapte à l'armée suisse
c'est les personnes qui sont suisses ici
l'autre option c'est la protection
civile
donc quand on passe d'un rêve
d'éclaireurs parachutistes à la
protection civile
c'est vraiment deux mondes qui sont
devant nous donc je suis fille rend
maintenant à l'après du consul en suisse
mais du coup de nouveaux jala j'ai dû
réussir à continuer à avancer malgré on
va dire cette grosse perte
le problème c'est que nouveau l'armée
suisse sait si on est vers l armée
suisse
on peut pas y revenir c'est impossible
donc c'était un chemin de nouveau pour
moi on va rencontrer à nouveau trouver
une autre solution
une autre voie j'ai pris donc le choix
le plus absurde de ma vie je suis
inscrit à hec lausanne
je sais que c'est un choix qui vous
paraîtrait logique je suis pas allé un
seul cours
je vous rassure tout celui mais non cgt
nul en maths et encore maintenant chez
nul en maths mais du coup je suis pas
allé un seul court mais j'ai trouvé une
autre école qui me plaisait quête un
rôle plus accès aux entrepreneurs je m'y
inscrire je fais six mois de cours avant
de entre parenthèses de nouveau échoué
l'année
je n'avais pas assez de bonnes notes
mais j'ai trouvé une passion
entreprendre parce que les cours par la
toujours comment réussir à faire le
marketing comment créer une start up
comment réussir à bien à vendre j'ai
voulu tester donc j'ai flairé un peu les
besoins pour ma classe 80% des personnes
qui foire est l'année c'est à cause de
la comptabilité
si les personnes la salle qui aiment la
comptabilité je vous respecte beaucoup
jeudi matin il ya peut-être un besoin là
donc on va appliquer tous libres de
marketing que la preuve nous balançant
tu es du matin au soir
on l'appliqué ont créé une page facebook
ont créé un logo ont créé une campagne
marketing on écrit à toutes les
personnes qui seraient potentiellement
intéressés par ces pour là on leur
envoie un mailing et loi tous on lance
maintenant enfin les cours de comptes a
passé grâce à nous votre année premier
cours mardi prochain
600 personnes potentielles personne
s'inscrit nouveau rosie maintenant il ya
un truc qui joue pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe et là on commence à un
brainstorming peu à 2 et aux écoutes
peut-être qu'on a fait une chose n'était
pas correct on relance un mail merci à
tous il reste plus qu'une place dans
inscriptions bouquet complet pour mardi
prochain
s'en est suivi quatre mois de booking
complet à easyjet rempli à ras bord donc
enfin qu'on voit on a réussi à créer une
sorte de start-up sam à l'entrée une
chose si je veux entreprendre
j'avais pas besoin de profs de livres
personnellement j'avais besoin de faire
les choses donc j'ai pris le risque de
quitter les bancs de l'école
son bachelor son master sans formation
valable en suisse pour me lancer
vraiment dans le monde de l'entreprise
sont les subi trois années d'échec
consécutifs d'argent beaucoup investi
dedans beaucoup investie d'énergie
beaucoup investi les équipes perdu des
amis perdus est vraiment ça a été très
très dur quand une start up c'est pas un
truc simple même si c'est très séduisant
j'écris plein de projets différents en
une heure une plateforme web de mise en
relation entre ménages privés et
étudiants une marque de brasser luxe
qu'on vendait aucune logique entre les
deux mais j'avais besoin de tester plein
de choses différentes pour comprendre
vraiment ce monde là pour me créer un
propres vaches leur personnel en start
up c'est je peux le dire aujourd'hui ça
fonctionne bien
j'ai une équipe j'envie suis entouré de
personnes magique bienveillante
passionné par ce qu'elles font donc j'ai
réussi que le temps on va dire à vivre
de mon activité mais qu'est ce que j'ai
appris à chacun de ses échecs
premièrement les chèques détruits et
c'est normal et c'est vital
il faut l'accepter hasek détruit pour
mieux reconstruire comme si une baraque
se casse la figure directement regarde
la base pourquoi se casser la figure
l'échec détruit mais au mieux
construire deuxième point que j'ai
appris vraiment important c'est l'échec
c'est pas nous il n'est pas interne
c'est pas nous qui sommes le chèque
c'est la pensée l'action le geste l'idée
qu'on a mis en place qui n'a pas
fonctionné très souvent si demain une
personne va un entretien d'embauché
qu'elle ressort qu'elle n'a pas réussir
le job et se dirait je suis un échec et
c'est absolument faux c'est pas nous
c'est ce qu'on a dit ce qu'on a fait
notre feuille qu'on m'a donné c'est pas
notre personne donc prendre l'achat
qu'une chose externe et non interne
vraiment très important l'autre point
l'échec est une des meilleures sources
d'apprentissage bien plus que la
réussite
j'en suis convaincu absolument à une
seule condition qu'on prenne le temps
d'amuser il faut analyser analyse et
analyser sans ça c'est juste un fossé
qu'on va créer et c'est important chaque
pas d'avoir une sorte de feedback attend
quels sont les cinq points j'ai réussi
vraiment à prendre actuellement pour
réussir à rebondir après un échec
premier point il faut accepter que
l'échec est possible bien très souvent
en fonce tête baissée
on veut créer une start up on est sûr
que ça a marché les copains nous posent
des questions c'est ça marche pas
t'inquiète pas ça marchera on connaît
tous une personne qui qui disent ah et
puis ça il faut être conscient que
l'échec est présent il est par là on
sait pas où il est il est par la
deuxième point il faut le préparer pas
le chercher une pas le provoquer mais
s'y préparent et personnellement c'était
maintenant faut être sûr que il ya deux
chemins qui s'ouvre devant nous il ya le
chemin de la réussite
le chemin de la chèque de
l'apprentissage il faut être conscient
qu'il est présent qu'il est là il faut
le préparer
se dire si demain je n'y arrive pas et
que par ici il faut juste savoir que ce
chemin existe et préparer cette vision
l'autre chemin qu'on pourra prendre
troisième point osé en parler c'est très
important et souvent on évite ces des
personnes à celles qui ont eu une
période de chômage
directement en cash on déguise nous
demande qu'est ce que tu as eue pour
l'emmener
j'ai un problème j'ai été vers et en os
pas en parler on déguise il faut en
parler c'est une expérience c'est par un
échec ce n'est pas une douleur c'est une
expérience et une force transformant sa
parlons-en
j'ai vécu personnellement j'ai annoncé à
mes parents que le créer une start up à
la famille au repas de noël c'est le
mark zuckerberg de la famille sauf que
j'avais par un pecos en poche la fin du
mois c'est louis tous les jours mais
juste un peu l'entrepreneur de famille
telepo posent la question tandis où ça
marche bien alors que ça marchait pas du
tout mais aucune n'a sur la dedans pas
c'est très dur elle dira quand j'en
parlais pas j'en parle à personne en
faut en parler c'est important faut en
parler
et si on en parle on va démystifier un
peu ce mot échec
quatrième point c'est le plus important
celui que maintenant je j'applique tout
le temps quand je nageais on avait très
souvent des coaches qui nous filmaient
et c'est maintenant aux plantes à une
course normale presque deux heures de
feedback sur une course est dure est
presqu'une milieu de la course à l'avant
un feedback constant sur nos coûts les
autres façons de penser ce qu'on ait
mangé avant son nez bien d'envié pas
dormi c'est de la clim pas trop
franchement il savait très très loin
dans les questions pour voir notre état
au jour la course on prenait tout ce qui
n'allait pas pascal et c'est bien ce qui
va on prenait ce qui allait pas pour
travailler analysé faire un feedback
faire un retour pour pouvoir remettre en
action
est ce qui découle directement sur
dernier point c'est revenir plus fort
elle est gros échec que j'ai vécu
personnellement ça ne pas avoir continué
à rabat que je voulais j'ai une soeur
qui fait de l'équitation qui se cassent
très souvent la figure de son cheval par
son assise violentes parfois mais à
chaque fois le remonte en selle
directement et j'aime bien cette image
de se dire que si on se casse la figure
ça peut arriver à tout le monde on est
tous humains avant tout et c'est
important vraiment de très vite remonter
en selle comme ça on en crée pas un
fossé
donc c'est un tremplin pour moi l'échec
c'est pas une chose négative c'est pas
un fossé c'est vraiment une chose qui
nous propulse plus haut ailleurs dans
une direction qui nous convient mieux
j'aime bien dire que
s'il ya une personne avec une période de
chômage ce n'est pas un échec
c'est une magnifique période
d'apprentissage c'est une personne qui a
planté une start up
c'est par un échec c'est pas une
faillite willemeau ces faillites on a
appris ce qu'il ne fallait pas refaire
pour la prochaine fois qu'on va créer
une start up changeant vraiment ce mot
échec par apprentissage dans nos têtes
et tout changera à dire j'ai subi une
période de chômage
j'ai appris plein de choses sur moi ce
que je voulais faire veut dire j'ai
planté une start up j'ai appris comment
ne plus planter
j'ai appris ce qu'il ne fallait pas
faire changeant ce mot dans le tête et
tout prendre à un autre sens il est
temps que notre société actuelle accepte
que l'échec est une magnifique source
d'apprentissage
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]